[Music]
why are some countries as a culture more
innovative than others right why do more
inventions come from one part of the
country relative to another now was it
would you say since the inception goods
at all levels right so you could have
entire countries feel in this way you
can have regions within a country we
have Silicon Valley right stuff coming
out of there
other places don't even within our
country are not matching what the
innovations that have emerged from
Silicon Valley over recent decades it's
an innovative community together to do
just that they're do just that and so
but don't you think it's a uniquely
American thing I mean I would say what
that what is that the fact now I don't
know this empirically yeah but my
perception and it could be because I'm
American and we're very
Amyris centric in this country so what
we get a zillion gold medals in the
Olympics and they're still cheery and I
would think it's my perception that we
innovate more than any nation in the
world generally I think in post-war post
Second World War right the 20th century
and a little bit in this entry I think
that's true yes so the question is can
we maintain it oh by the way I don't if
they can see out the front window the
the amber-colored building up there that
is a famous high school the Stuyvesant
High Stuyvesant yes a high school of
science and math
and they're these sort of the regional
competitors to the Bronx Roxanna yeah
did you go to Brussels XProtect ice it's
a famous Bronx Science broad science has
eight Nobel laureates counted among its
graduates sweet seven in physics and one
I think in chemistry and it's it's a
it's a point of pride I think that is
and then you say well how do you
duplicate this in other cities and how
do you and now we talk about innovation
oh we go right the country of Spain okay
has eight Nobel Prizes the whole country
the whole country right and Bronx
Science bowties has among its graph has
a tongue and the red country is Spain
Spain so we have one high school with
more Nobel laureates than an entire
country
correct now of course where did you hear
that
you know so my issue here is obviously
there are many many countries that have
never won any Nobel prizes so picking
countries that don't have as many Nobel
prizes as my high school is not the
point here
the point is I pick Spain because Spain
spent at least a century I would counted
it two centuries of its history as
explorers that's true X Wars and if they
were to explore never pain as we know
from Christopher Columbus's Christopher
Columbus right and so and wait wait we
got a pen we're going to come now yeah
it's about to pass Canal Street up ahead
famous Canal Street which used to have
it back when the Dutch were here if that
Canal Street connects to the Holland
Tunnel like dogs by peeing on every tree
Dutch have left their left their mark
everywhere can outdate in the
Netherlands most of that country's below
sea level right so after global warming
rises the oceans they'll be fun they
just build more die or die this is what
they do this is like how they do it so
wait a minute I'm back to Spain why did
you pick
oh because they have a legacy of
exploration and discovery so I want to
hold them accountable for a cultural
attitude that pervaded their land my god
see what I'm saying you hear that Spain
you just got served
okay you can't go to lose Becca stand
and say I got more Nobel Prize than you
unless there's some history there right
or some award or Biafra whatever
whatever they call today you can't
that's not the right kind of comparison
so I go to said I said I was in Spain
this past summer and I went up to some
of the Spaniards and I said what gives
and so they say well you know things are
different people thinking during
survival mode economically rather than
thriving mode where that which gives you
the freedom freedom to freedom of
thought freedom to talk to places where
you have a luxury which of imagining a
future that you have the power to create
absolutely you know and networks the
same way in the art world too so if you
were wealthy you could pursue art mm-hmm
you know so everybody thinks like art
everywhere all over the world
and I think that's more because you have
an individualistic approach to art and
so it really is formed in the mind you
don't have to follow any rules I mean
right gotta follow some rules yes but
the converse is the ultimate judge jury
and executioner right the universe is
Judge Dredd